bonjour mais détaille m
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt
france on l'a vu beaucoup de voix
s'élèvent justement pour demander la
grâce pour julian assange également en
tunisie où vous êtes particulièrement
penchée sur cette question
alors oui en fait toutes les personnes à
travers le monde qui sont contre
l'injustice et pour la vérité sont
absolument scandalisée par ce qui ce
parce que si tu as subi du lan assange
pendant dix ans aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas qu'on parle ici de
quelqu'un qui a été persécuté pendant
dix ans qu'il a subi c'est quand la
terre en anglais un lot faire ce à dire
une guerre juridique
donc il ya plusieurs manières de se
débarrasser d'une personne de la faire
taire et l'une d'elles qui est à la mode
depuis plusieurs heures à quelques
années qui avaient utilisée notamment
contre l'ancien président lula et puis
la présidente brésilienne et puis aussi
le président en fait non c'est un
président équatorien rafael correa
cc voilà c'est de les mettre dans la
machine judiciaire comment des années et
des années
voilà pour les empêcher de faire leur
travail donc c'est ce qu'a subi du lien
d'assange
c'est ce que subit tu la nation jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on sait pas si le 4 janvier
la juge va décider de le libérer ou pas
et voilà donc évidemment que enfin de
plus en plus de gens sont scandalisés à
travers le monde
surtout que les gens ouvrent de plus en
plus les yeux sur la réalité de cette
affaire que c'est vraiment une
persécution de la journaliste
donc il n'a rien fait d'autre qu'un
travail de journaliste assez
exceptionnel d'ailleurs vlc courageux
puisqu'il n'avait pas elle avait décidé
de ne pas s'arrêter à la limite que que
malheureusement journalistes observent
qui est celle de ne pas publier des
choses qui peuvent trop fâché de
l'empiré étasunien et voilà donc donc
aujourd'hui on est dans cette situation
extrêmement difficile et d'une nation je
risque vraiment de mourir en prison ça
il faut le savoir des médecins
implantent ausculter les médecins l'ont
enfin des psychologues des psychiatres à
en analyser l'on écouté et ils ont
vraiment décelé des problèmes qui
peuvent être extrêmement grave qui peut
donner à saint marc
alors justement ces derniers jours le
rapporteur de l'onu sur la torture a une
nouvelle fois demandé la libération de
julian assange est ce que c'est une voie
importante avant le verdict alors oui
monsieur nice melzer donc depuis alors
lui aussi justement depuis maintenant à
peu près de deux ans a ouvert les yeux
sur la réalité de ce qui se passe et de
ce qui arrivait à d'une passion il avait
lui-même avoué monsieur mêmes terres que
il était tombé dans le piège de la
propagande étasunienne qui avait
toujours des pins monsieur assange comme
étant presque un criminel un décor donc
depuis deux ans il a ouvert les yeux et
en fait il est passé d'une extrême à
l'autre d'une position ne l'était plus
ou moins ambivalents par rapport à
dublin assange à quelqu'un à l'un des
plus grands défenseurs de julian assange
mais oui alors d'un côté vous avez
effectivement un expert de l'onu sur la
torture notamment donc monsieur mail
terre et mais de l'autre côté vous avez
l'empiré étasunien qui qui a mis en
place toute sa machine à détruire donc
vous pour essayer de 2,2 déjà deux déjà
empêché de la récense de faire son
travail
et puis aussi de le détruire lui aussi
au passage que pensez vous du fait que
les médias internationaux les médias
mainstream notamment ne se préoccupe pas
particulièrement de duca assange c'est
plutôt des blogs comme le vôtre liberté
info d'ailleurs qui qui se mobilisent
pour pour tenter de le faire libérer que
pensez vous de ce silence
alors oui c'est une très bonne question
en fait ça révèle en fait une crise du
journalisme qui arrive d'ailleurs en
france on voit bien les conséquences
aujourd'hui
je vous rappelle qu'en france pour forer
petite parenthèse en avril 2019 donc à
peu près même pas deux semaines après le
l'arrestation le kidnapping on devrait
dire de julian assange au sein de
l'ambassade équatorien d'hallendre donc
à peine deux semaines après il y avait
la dgs si en france qui a convoqué les
journalistes disent clause qui avait
révélé les ventes à ce que les ventes
d'armes françaises pouvaient servir à
des crimes de guerre au yémen
et donc voilà malheureusement décédé
petit c'est généralement des
journalistes indépendants ou des petites
structures journaliste journalistique
musée vous à part peut-être la vôtre qui
est on peut dire presque mais inscrits
mais qui fait un travail objectif à ce
niveau là donc donc effectivement même
malheureusement beaucoup de journalistes
connaissent cette limite inquiets la
limite de voir de vampires états unis et
qu'il faut surtout pas à fâcher donc je
sais comme ça que je vois les choses
merci beaucoup mais dit ayem d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france